- So Charithra, social media has praised
casting darker skin, Indian actors.
So what has this meant for you?
- Colorism has existed at different times
throughout history.
- Yeah.
- And I think it is particularly pervasive
in countries in Asia and in Africa
and South Asia and East Asia
because of, well one, colonialism
and second to do with class and caste
and so, you know, it's
a daily struggle for us
'cause we're never allowed to forget it.
And it, I always say it
feels kind of violent to me
because it's comes from
within your own community.
- Yeah.
- And so I just hope that
Simone and I being in the show
can help dark skinned people of all races
to feel beautiful and to feel seen
and to feel worthy of love.
- Yeah, absolutely.
(audience cheering)
And it's also like one of my,
we love the artwork by the way
and when people dress up, we love it.
- Oh my God.
- And one of my favorite ones
is of these two children who were dressed
up as the Duke and Lady Danbury.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like growing up, I didn't have,
I didn't know who to dress
up for Halloween parties.
- Exactly, yeah.
- I felt ridiculous
dressing up as Cinderella
or Sleeping Beauty.
I was so scared people
would ask me who I was,
even though I obviously was Belle.
- Yeah.
- You know,
and so for young girls to be
able to dress up as a dowager
- Yeah.
- and a duke and you know,
a princess and all of
these things is amazing.